antes de que te pidan que te vayas.
Crecí en Atlanta, Georgia,
rebotando de casa en casa
con una familia amorosa y unida
mientras luchábamos por encontrar estabilidad
en nuestras finanzas.
Pero cuando mi madre cayó temporalmente en la locura
y cuando esa locura me eligió como su principal chivo expiatorio
mediante abuso emocional y físico,
hui por mi seguridad.
Llegué a la conclusión de que la carencia de vivienda era más seguro para mí
que estar en casa.
Tenía 16 años.
Durante mi falta de vivienda, me uní a los 3300 jóvenes sin hogar de Atlanta
que se sentían desamparados,
excluidos e invisibles cada noche.
No había ni hay ningún lugar
para que un menor sin hogar salga de la calle
y acceda a una cama.
Me di cuenta de que la mayoría de la gente pensaba en la vida en la calle
como un tipo de haraganería y debilidad inducidas por las drogas,
pero eso no representaba mi mochila llena de ropa y libros escolares,
o mi promedio de notas A+.
Me sentaba en mi banco favorito en el centro
y dejaba pasar las horas
hasta que podía colarme unas pocas horas de sueño
en sofás, en autos,
en edificios o en centros de almacenamiento.
Yo, como miles de jóvenes sin hogar, desaparecía en las sombras de la ciudad
mientras todo el mundo seguía girando
como si nada hubiera ido de verdad tan mal.
La invisibilidad sola casi rompió mi espíritu.
Pero cuando no tenía nada más, tenía las artes,
algo que no demanda
riqueza material de mi parte a cambio de refugio.
Algunas horas de canto, escribiendo poesía
o ahorrando suficiente dinero
para desaparecer en otro mundo en una obra de teatro
me mantuvo y me devolvió a la vida cuando me sentí en mi punto más bajo.
Iba a los servicios de la iglesia los miércoles en la noche
y, desesperada por el alivio que las artes me daban,
me iba unas horas antes,
deslizándome hacia abajo
en una parte del mundo donde lo único que importaba
era si podía o no alcanzar la nota correcta en la canción
que estaba perfeccionando esa semana.
Cantaba durante horas.
Me dio tanta fuerza para darme la licencia
de simplemente bloquear todo y cantar.
Cinco años después, comencé mi organización ChopArt,
que es una organización artística multidisciplinaria para menores sin hogar.
ChopArt usa las artes como herramienta para la recuperación del trauma
tomando lo que sabemos sobre la construcción de la comunidad,
restaurando la dignidad
y aplicando eso al proceso creativo.
ChopArt tiene su sede en Atlanta, Georgia,
con programas adicionales en Hyderabad, India, y Accra, Ghana,
y desde nuestro comienzo en 2010,
hemos servido a más de 40 000 adolescentes en todo el mundo.
Nuestros adolescentes se refugian
en los elementos transformadores de las artes,
y dependen del espacio seguro que ChopArt les brinda para que lo hagan.
Una población a menudo invisible usa las artes para entrar en su luz,
pero ese viaje de la invisibilidad no es fácil.
Tenemos un par de hermanos, Jeremy y Kelly,
que han estado en nuestro programa más de tres años.
Vienen a las clases de ChopArt todos los miércoles por la noche.
Pero hace aproximadamente un año,
Jeremy y Kelly presenciaron cómo su madre se quitaba la vida muriendo ante ellos.
Vieron como los paramédicos no pudieron revivirla.
Lloraron cuando su padre
firmó la custodia temporal a su mentora de ChopArt, Erin,
sin siquiera permitirles llevar ropa adicional en su salida.
Estos eventos me rompieron el corazón
pero la fe y la resolución de Jeremy y Kelly en ChopArt
es lo que me mantiene con fuerza en este trabajo.
Kelly llamando a Erin en su momento más bajo,
sabiendo que Erin haría lo que pudiera
para hacer que se sintieran amados y cuidados,
es una prueba para mí de que, al usar las artes como punto de entrada,
podemos sanar y construir nuestra población juvenil sin hogar.
Y continuamos construyendo.
Construimos con Devin,
que se quedó sin hogar con su familia
cuando su madre tuvo que elegir entre facturas médicas o el alquiler.
Descubrió su amor por la pintura a través de ChopArt.
Construimos con Liz,
quien ha estado en la calle la mayor parte de su adolescencia,
pero recurre a la música para regresar a sí misma